members of Congress from both parties
are sharply denouncing the president's
unwillingness to defend US intelligence
agencies Republican Senator John McCain
called it one of the most disgraceful
performances by an American president in
memory former Vice President Joe Biden a
potential Democratic candidate in 2020
said the news conference was beneath the
dignity of the office of the president
Republican House Speaker Paul Ryan wrote
the United States must be focused on
holding Russia accountable and putting
an end to its vile attacks on democracy
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill talking
to other lawmakers Nancy good morning
good morning brutal criticism and that's
because most Republicans were already at
odds with the president when it comes to
Russia but now there is a real sense of
defeat a sense that they will never be
able to get through to him on this issue
though that didn't stop some of them
from trying
there's no friend to America GOP leaders
tried to be gentle other Republicans
were more blunt president's comments
made us look as a nation more like a
pushover what the president said today
is not accurate Arizona's Jeff Flake
called it shameful I never thought I'd
see an American president throw the
intelligence community under the bus
like that it's unbelievably
disappointing Texas Republican will Hurd
is a former CIA agent I've seen Russian
intelligence manipulate a lot of people
and I never would have thought that the
u.s. president would be one of those
ones I'm getting duped by an old KGB
hand Democrats were even more scathing
it's got to be a new low even for this
president absolutely disgraceful I was
horrified by what I saw
they say Congress should rebuke or
censure the commander in chief the
former CIA director John Brennan called
the president's comments treason do you
agree with that I certainly agree that
it was a betrayal of America's interests
and inexplicable betrayal Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer offered one
controversial explanation Russians
blackmail Americans are scratching their
head and saying if that's not the
explanation that Putin has something on
it what is it what they
could it be Republican leaders have been
discussing the possibility of passing a
resolution that would express support
for the US intelligence community and
its findings but there is widespread
skepticism about what that would
actually achieve after all Congress
passed two similar resolutions just in
the past week one on trade one
supporting NATO and both times John the
president didn't appear to change his
mind or his actions Nancy thanks so much